hello everyone and welcome back to the
commission's press room
today is still wednesday the 9th of june
and you really feel it
in brussels for the heat we're here for
a
press conference on a competition sector
inquiry
we will have to finish this press
conference at two o'clock
so without further ado i'll give the
floor to executive vice president mr
sagar that is here with us today
well thank you very much and it is
indeed a beautiful day in
in brussels today the commission
has published the preliminary findings
uh of its competition inquiry
into the internet of things sector
inquiries
they help us to identify potential
competition concerns
in markets where early intervention may
be needed
this is all the more important in
markets with strong network effects
scale effects and that are growing and
developing
the consumer internet of things is a
relatively new sector
and it is booming for example more than
half of europeans well they would watch
their favorite show on a smart
tv last year and revenues from smart
home appliances they are predicted to
double
and to almost reach 40 billion euros in
2025
it's precisely because the internet of
things is developing
fast that we need to ensure that it does
so
in a competitive way all firms
in growing sectors should have the same
opportunity to innovate and to bring new
products and services
to the market we saw indications
of some practices that we know too well
may lead to tipping and to the emergence
of
gatekeepers and this is why we launched
the sector inquiry less than a year ago
and from that preliminary results
published today
it appears that our concerns they are
shared by
many players it's too early to say
but if some of these uh practices are
confirmed it could lead to new
competition cases uh being opened
so far the results of the sector inquiry
confirm the central role of operating
systems
and voice assistance in the
interconnection of different smart
devices and services
and respondents flag that this may give
providers
of operating systems and voice
assistance
opportunities to engage in behaviors
that negatively affects competition
in the eu uh google assistants
amazon's alexa and apple's siri
are the leading voice assistants in
addition
google amazon and apple well they
provide the main
operating systems for smart home and
wearable
devices they offer it into services and
they manufacture
smart devices
in practice these companies they
determine
how different devices and services can
communicate
communicate and interoperate with one
another
in addition voice assistants well
they learn a lot about us their users
smart devices and internet of things
services
they generate huge amounts of data
about what we do in our homes
four main concerns have been reported in
the inquiry
so far first there can be restrictions
on
multi-homing second there are concerns
about
default settings and pre-installations
of voice assistance
third there are concerns about data
accumulation
and finally there are concerns about
interoperability
let me describe these four concerns in
more detail
first there are concerns about the
attempts to restrict
the number of voice assistance
accessible on smart devices
for example this means that producers of
smart devices can be
prevented from installing a second
voice assistant on one device
if this was indeed the case well
consumer's choice would be restricted
second there are concerns that voice
assistant providers
could take over the direct relationship
with users
the reason is that users control and
access
their device and services via the voice
assistant
voice assistant providers can promote
their own
products their own services or services
of third-party providers
of their choice and this can be done
with the default settings and with
giving
prominence to specific services
third voice assistants collect enormous
amounts of data this could be data about
the average temperature
in your kitchen the time you get up in
the morning
your favorite newspaper maybe even
how you like to drink your coffee
having access to this data gives big
advantages in in particular
as voice assistants accumulate data from
different devices
and different services
finally there seems to be a limited
interoperability between
products services technologies of
different providers
and this is partly due to the lack of
common standards
and the prevalence of proprietary
technology
the limited interoperability that might
lock in consumers
using devices and services are mainly
one or few providers
this reduces their choice and the
possibilities
of uh of easily switching
and that of course raises competition
concerns
these preliminary findings of ours well
they are based
on input received from more than 200
companies
that responded to our questionnaire and
shared with us
more than 1 000 contracts
we had responses from companies of all
sizes
from asia from the european union and
from the u.s
these concerns offer these companies
offer smart devices such as smart
speakers smart tvs smart coffee makers
fitness trackers or smart watches
we also received input from companies
offering voice assistance
or digital services like music and video
streaming
we are very thankful for the cooperation
with these many many businesses for all
that input received
that allows us to give this horizontal
overview
of a strongly growing sector
for our final report we still need to
better understand the extent
of the concerns and this is why today
with the publication our preliminary
findings
we are launching a public consultation
this will run
until the first of september
we invite all businesses interested
citizens
stakeholders to share with us their
feedback
on our preliminary findings and all this
information will provide guidance to our
future
activities our enforcement work
but of course also to the commission's
regulatory
work many of the issues
identified so far such as access to data
access to users barriers to switching
well they are familiar themes from our
enforcement activity in digital markets
in fact uh a number of these practices
reported in the sector inquiry
they um they feature in the do's and
don'ts
of the commission's proposal that didn't
markets act
with today's preliminary findings and
work to be done in the coming months
the sector inquiry will certainly
contribute
to the debates on the scope of the
digital markets act
through competition enforcement and
complementary
legislation we aim to create a digital
economy
that works for everyone to do so
we must make sure that our digital
markets
including the consumer internet of
things
are open fair for consumers with room
for businesses of all sizes
to innovate and grow and this is why we
look
forward to a further engagement from
businesses
from citizens and from all interested
stakeholders in the coming months thank
you very much
thanks to you executive vice president i
think we're now ready to take your
questions
as always i would ask you to raise your
hand if you have a question you would
like to ask
first in relation to the preliminary
report on the
sector inquiry into the consumer
internet of things
that the executive vice president has
just presented to us and then we will
eventually take
questions on other competition cases
also grateful that you can say
your name and the media outlet for which
you work
i see lewis has his hand raised luis
hi can you hear me hi yes hi yes
excellent
is the obligatory can you hear me at the
beginning of the question um
two questions um how urgent are these
concerns
do you think you need to start
intervening now or will you only
intervene
at the end of this inquiry and the
second question
commissioner do you yourself use voice
assistance
if so which ones or if not why not
as to the first question sense of
urgency uh
so far no uh specific cases has sort of
sprung
up uh from the draft report uh
we need uh the feedback from the sector
in order to assess uh
the extent of the concerns uh but
obviously
having seen what is coming uh we are
on our toes uh because this is a really
fast moving market
and we need to keep an eye out on the
second
i think there are a voice assistant in
my phone uh
i don't use that and i
the landlord of my apartment i think the
appliances they were bought
give or take 1995 or something like that
and they worked perfectly well but that
was before the internet of things really
was
a big thing if anything so so no
i do not have a voice assistant except
from what is in my phone
in my home and i don't use that
thank you very much i see another hand
raised
catherine is it in relation to
this topic
the one of the sectors it is go ahead
then thanks
thank you there already appear to be
uh dominant players in this sector
um i mean has the horse already bolted
in a sense
um because you know the first the first
movers obviously have an advantage
and um
i mean it may be by the time the your
guest right taking any action
that might be too lit um can you think
i mean can you act retractlessly if you
think
that uh there are people who have
a position in this market that is maybe
dominant and maybe
unfair i and and what to what extent are
you working with
uh data protection people one of the
concerns that i have is when you go into
other people's
homes or uh working
close to other people they choose to use
these you know alexa or whatever
and you are you end up giving
your data to some extent i'm not sure
mine would be terribly interesting
but to to those
providers without your consent so to
what extent
are you working with the data protection
people thank you
on on the first uh the question if uh
if this is already too late if the
market is already tipped
uh into being dominated by very few
companies
as said we see three main service
providers here
and we see that it is growing most
europeans
would have at least a smart tv in their
home
so it's a real thing uh if we
find confirmation that there are
specific cases
uh to look at we will do that uh
immediately
the second thing is that erases a debate
uh about uh the scope of the dental
markets act
uh here it is a real debate because a
voice assistant is not
real sort of intermediation in some
circumstance it can be seen as in other
circumstances not
but that of course is an interesting
debate because part of the do's and
don'ts
that we have in the proposal of the
digital markets act
addresses exactly some of the concerns
that we have seen from market players
about data accumulation uh lack of
interoperability
uh so i think that is a a debate that
will hopefully uh pick up
uh in the coming months
maybe as an illustration of the fact
that in order to have
an an open uh contestable market when it
comes also to the internet of things
we both need vigilant competition law
enforcement
and for and maybe also for regulation
uh to kick in we work with
data protection authorities uh whenever
there is any reason to do so
obviously here also on the in the
internet of things
the gdpr will apply
the thing is still even if we as
consumers
have rights it can still be very tricky
to enforce
uh those rights uh once you uh have the
appliances
uh in your home so obviously it's for
the commission at large
a priority to make sure that
it becomes as easy as possible to
actually
enforce your rights as a consumer to
protect your privacy
thank you i see that ifa would like to
ask a question
to the executive vice president
questions um how widespread do you see
the use of these devices
voice assistance and have they become a
point where it's a must-have to have a
fitness tracker or a voice assistant
and do you see much chance of smaller
companies even trying to enter this
space i mean do you see it you talked
about the barriers of entry
but do you see attempted market entry at
all or is it really a game only for
the big players
i i definitely do not think it's a
must-have
i think it's the choice if you want to
and even if you buy a new appliance it's
a choice if you want to connect it
i think most coffee makers they will
still make coffee and not insist that
they must be connected
to the internet in order to provide you
with a with a newly brewed uh cup of
coffee
so i think there is an element of choice
here uh
as to what kind of home do you want to
have
uh i see a lot of potential uh in the
internet of things
uh because if if done rightly so that
consumers are in control
of the data and how they use it it can
provide a lot of
uh convenience uh in in your everyday
life as to how your home is working uh
how you
uh how you use electricity
how you you know all these many many
things that are being offered
but i think it is a real a real choice
if you want to use it or not even if
it's
uh in the in the in the appliances or
not
uh we still see that that there is a a
market that is open there are there are
other
manufacturers uh of smart devices uh
then what what is uh just for for a
google
amazon and apple
but the reason why we found it really
important to do this sector inquiry
was of course that we had concerns that
in a fast-moving market there may be a
risk of tipping and the other concerns
that i mentioned that we found to be
shared
with market participants so obviously
it's really important for us to stay
vigilant
so that those other businesses who are
there
they have a real fair chance to compete
uh
against uh the big ones and that the
market is open for innovation
uh because i definitely do not think
that we have seen the last
uh item connected to the internet on the
contrary
many many items will still feature
connectivity thanks
i will now give the floor to yunji
the dma expected to be passed next year
the chances of you opening any
individual cases would appear to be
quite slim isn't it
would you agree
um well it's it's it's difficult to say
um you know the last sector inquiry we
did
uh the one into e-commerce uh i think it
produced
uh four anti-trust cases
three on resale price maintenance and
one on geo-blocking
and at the same time that sector inquiry
inspired a number
of uh of companies to revise
uh their own behavior in the marketplace
and i think that was quite a good result
of that sector inquiry
so i think it's too early to say uh if
this sector inquiry will produce
specific cases
uh or not
thank you i do not see other hands
raised for the time being so if you have
a question still
on the topic of the day it's your moment
necklace
one two one two here you well hi
hello executive vice president it's um
nicholas hurst from
mlex um uh it's a question
on a different topic i hope that's um
that's okay now it's um
about the announcements but the
announcement by google
yesterday on the android case
the top of the day but i do not see
other hands raised
so if it's okay for the executive vice
president i would indeed move to
other competition questions of course we
are always here to answer it we still
have phrase on the sector inquiry so
please nick let's go ahead
um so on yesterday's announcements
this idea of a choice screen without an
auction so a free
choice screen displaying a whole series
of
rivals that's been used in other
internet cases in the past in particular
the
the microsoft browser one um that's now
the final landing point for
for the android case could you see do
you see this as a model
for other platform cases would would you
like to see or would you encourage
other platforms to look at this as as a
possible solution to
antitrust cases um in the in digital
sector
um and the second question on google if
uh
if i can squeeze it in um that was about
android
there are of course still complaints out
there about the google shopping remedy
if you have any update on that we'll be
interested
thank you very much
um first on the the google shopping
case the latest updates because
obviously we're still following
it really close is that the rate of
of display of offers from competitors
of googles well that now make up to
almost 75 percent of the total
uh inventory of the shopping unit
and uh almost 90 percent
of the shopping units uh displayed by
google they would have at least
one offer from competitors of the
of google uh give or take 50
of clicks uh within the shopping unit
they are
on an offer from competitors of google
so it's it's a really different
situation uh from what it was
uh it's still very difficult for
shopping comparison services
uh but in the shopping unit itself
uh quite a lot of changes over these
years
on the uh the announcements on on the
changes of the android
remedy i really welcome this
we have been actively discussing uh with
google
uh with the complainants and i think uh
this is uh this is much better it's a
free model
so you don't pay to be in uh the numbers
of uh of providers um
they will be increased uh both on
on the first uh first screen but also
you can scroll
and there will be a random appearance
on the first screen you will have uh the
search providers with the biggest market
shares but it will be randomized
so it's not a given that the one with
the biggest market share will always be
on top it will be rolled out by by 1st
of september
and obviously we will follow very very
closely
the results of of these improvements
whether or not that's a solution to
other cases
i think that really depends on the case
so
remains to be seen depending on on the
case specifics
we have on the floor two questions on
other competition matters i do not see
other hands raised for the time being so
if there's a question you would like to
ask as mr vice president
it's your moment to raise your hand
i'll just give it a couple of minutes
or actually seconds
still no hands raised it looks like we
were very clear on all topics of the day
or in general on
uh on competition good
uh of course you know very well that we
are always available to
answer to to your queries so let me just
uh
thank executive president for being here
with us to you
for having joined the translators
colleagues that set it up and worked
on on the press material and and all the
rest uh let me also remind you that we
will be back
in the press room at 2 45 for
a technical back technical briefing on
background apologies
on the preliminary report of this sector
inquiry for accredited journalists only
as you know
all our technical briefings uh and now i
will give the line to
london to commissioner seth cevich and
to daniel ferry
bye thanks
very good